cada pequeño cuadrado de la siguiente
cuadrícula
tiene un área de una unidad cuadrada así
que cada uno de estos cuadrados tiene un
área de una unidad cuadrada aquí tenemos
una unidad cuadrada aquí también hay
otra unidad cuadrada y así sucesivamente
y bueno ahora nos piden dibujar un
rectángulo con un área de 10 unidades
cuadradas y bueno esta palabra área es
muy importante porque a lo que se
refiere es a cuánto espacio cubre una
figura
hombre
eso quiere decir que nuestra figura en
este caso es un rectángulo debe de
cubrir un espacio de 10 unidades
cuadradas y sabemos que cada uno de
estos cuadrados es de una unidad
cuadrada así que queremos encontrar un
rectángulo que cubra 10 pequeños
cuadrados así que tal vez lo primero que
se te ocurra es intentar dibujar un
rectángulo usando la primera fila y
decir bueno aquí tengo uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete unidades
cuadradas y ese es un problema porque la
fila de hasta arriba solamente tiene
siete unidades cuadradas y nosotros
necesitamos diez unidades cuadradas así
que no es suficiente y tampoco funciona
si hacemos una columna de 10 unidades
cuadradas porque si observas la columna
tiene una
3 456 unidades cuadradas solamente
tenemos seis unidades cuadradas así que
no podríamos dibujar el rectángulo que
buscamos de esta manera porque
necesitamos diez unidades cuadradas es
por eso que vamos a tener que dividir
nuestras diez unidades cuadradas en
grupos iguales así que en lugar de
fijarnos en una columna o una fila vamos
a fijarnos en grupos de unidades
cuadradas es por eso que podemos dividir
estas diez unidades cuadradas
y bueno se me ocurren dos grupos de
cinco unidades cuadradas o bueno también
lo podemos ver de manera contraria cinco
grupos de dos unidades cuadradas ambas
formas funcionan así que qué te parece
si lo hacemos así que si empezamos justo
por aquí y agarramos un rectángulo de
dos filas con cinco unidades cuadradas
cada fila se va a ver más o menos así y
te puedes dar cuenta porque podemos
contar las unidades cuadradas que
tenemos este rectángulo cubre una dos
tres cuatro cinco unidades cuadradas en
su primera fila y la segunda fila tiene
otras cinco unidades cuadradas y lo
podemos ver aquí 6 7 8 9 10 unidades
cuadradas así que este rectángulo
completo cubren 10 unidades cuadradas o
tiene un área de 10 unidades cuadradas
así que esta es una respuesta perfecta
un rectángulo que tenga
dos filas y cada una de las filas tenga
cinco unidades cuadradas y ojo podríamos
haber dibujado este mismo rectángulo en
cualquier parte de la cuadrícula pudimos
haberlo dibujado aquí dos filas una dos
tres cuatro cinco unidades cuadradas un
rectángulo aquí o tal vez acá abajo dos
filas y cinco unidades cuadradas o donde
sea porque cualquier rectángulo que
tenga dos filas de cinco unidades
cuadradas cada fila va a tener un área
de 10 unidades cuadradas y de manera
similar cualquier rectángulo que cubra
cinco filas de dos unidades cuadradas va
a tener un área de 10 unidades cuadradas
es más vamos a intentar dibujarlo por
aquí voy a dibujar un rectángulo que
tenga cinco filas va a empezar por aquí
va a tener cinco filas dos tres cuatro y
esta es la quinta
dos unidades cuadradas cada fila aquí lo
tenemos este
cubre un área de 10 unidades cuadradas
observa aquí tenemos una 2 tenemos filas
de dos unidades cuadradas y tenemos
cinco filas entonces vamos a tener 12
4 5 6 7 8 9 y 10 10 unidades cuadradas
así que de nuevo este rectángulo cubre
10 unidades cuadradas y cualquier
rectángulo que tú puedas dibujar aquí en
esta cuadrícula que tenga ya sea dos
filas de cinco unidades cuadradas o
cinco filas de dos unidades cuadradas
será un rectángulo con un área de 10
unidades cuadradas que es justo lo que
queríamos